during a rainstorm any light source used
to illuminate the scene will also
reflect off of nearby raindrops
for example the headlights of a car
driving at night well not only brighten
the road they also brighten the drops
causing distracting flashes
in this paper we present a method that
uses high speed adaptive projection to
illuminate the scene but not illuminate
the drops this will give the driver
better visibility at a time when it is
most needed
this illustration demonstrates our basic
idea the car's headlights illuminate the
scene and some light rays intersect
drops these illuminated drops will
appear as bright flickering distracting
streaks
however if we can determine the rays
that are illuminating only drops we can
momentarily turn them off
as the drops are moving quickly each
rate will spend alene an imperceptible
fraction of a second off giving the
driver the impression of headlights dead
see-through rain we capture images with
either a stereo camera pair or a
co-located camera projector system once
the image is acquired we quickly process
the image to detect the particle and
predict its future location when we are
finally able to update the lighting to
not illuminate it using simulation we
have investigated the requirements for
such a system to be feasible here is a
simulation of rain five millimeters per
hour with the system latency of 13
milliseconds our adaptive projection
system runs at 120 Hertz this first
example is a simulation with a
stationary camera black streaks are the
drops successfully not illuminated the
red streaks at the top our drops of the
system is not yet recognized if we add
forward velocity the drops enter the
field of view from the top and the sides
which makes the test challenging though
not impossible at 30 kilometres per hour
the accuracy is 73% at very high speeds
our system is still capable of not
illuminating many of the drops while
still maintaining high light throughput
we have also created a prototype camera
projector system that detects drops and
adaptively adjust the illumination the
system consists of a co-located camera
and projector both running at 120 Hertz
based on the captured images this
prototype system adapts the projector
lighting every 8 milliseconds this video
shows how the system operates on a
single drop the camera input is fed into
our system which predicts the future
location of the drop and directs the
projector to not illuminate it for the
predicted location video the color red
indicates the parts of the drop that are
incorrectly illuminated green indicates
the parts of the drop that are correctly
not illuminated and blue indicates
pixels that were incorrectly turned off
this video shows multiple drops released
from different drop emitters the system
is able to track and predict the future
locations of each drop at 120 Hertz
shown here are drops falling at 32 drops
per second which is equivalent to a
severe thunderstorm the drops are
following against the background with
varying brightness and contrast levels
to simulate nighttime driving on a busy
road as can be seen the visibility is
much improved when the illumination is
reactively controlled increasing the
system speed and performance will make
adaptive headlights a real possibility
making driving and inclement weather
safer and less stressful